So it's not obvious on first consideration why discussed would be a moral
emotion.
So you know,
most of the work that's done,
it's outside of the disgust realm I would say is predicated on the assumption
that the reason that conservatives in particular,
but perhaps people who are more authoritarian and general draw boundaries around
their territories because they're afraid of the other.
But that isn't really,
that isn't really how it plays out as far as I can tell.
Because conservatives for example,
are less neurotic than treat in the big five traits sense than liberals.
Although it's,
it's a minor difference.
But the disgust issue seems to be particularly relevant.
So,
so can you tell us a little bit about why disgust per se?
Well,
first conservatives are a little less neurotic,
but they also add,
if you do very low level perceptual experiment,
just like a puff of white noise in the ear,
people who react more strongly to that to any sort of very low level threat are
more likely to vote Republican in this country.
So they're there.
You know,
there are all these interesting personality differences that lead to different
politics.
But as for why discussed?
Um,
so I'm,
I'm uh,
Durkheimian I would say I love the,
uh,
the sociologists,
Emile Durkheim,
and I'm also,
I'm a social psychologist,
so I'm always thinking not about people as individual utility maximizers but
people as members of social groups,
people who are totally focused on belonging in their social groups and people
who have some pro social motives about keeping the group together,
about doing things that are good for the group.
So as I tried to argue in my book,
the righteous mind,
yes,
we're selfish.
There's no doubt that we often will do things to advance our own self interest
at the expense of others.
But we're also really groupish,
which means we'll do all sorts of things to advance Eric Group at the expense of
others.
Basically,
we're tribal,
we evolved as a tribal species and we're doing,
we have all this software,
I would know all this,
all these predispositions,
these mental predispositions for life in,
in tribes that are battling other tribes.
And that's why it comes out so easily.
If you look at the way boys organized themselves when they get up fraternity,
um,
the hazing rituals,
when you look at the weight,
it's especially clear in boys,
uh,
the way street gangs organized themselves.
Girls,
tribalism is a little different.
Um,
but I would say this is,
and that's why,
again,
I love the [inaudible] approach of archetypes or something.
There's just this weird stuff that is pan human.
Even if it comes out slightly differently around the world,
there really is a human nature and it comes complete with a whole bunch of like,
predesigned ideas.